dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here what a
wonderful day to talk about fluid
simulations this technique is an
extension to smooth particle
hydrodynamics or SPH in short which is a
widely used particle based simulation
technique where the visual quality
scales with a number of simulated
particles the more particles we use in
the simulation the more eye candy we can
expect and the goal here is to create an
extension of these SPH based simulations
to include deformable bodies and
granular materials to the computations
this way it is possible to create a
scene where we have instant coffee and
soft candy dissolving in water which not
only looks beautiful but sounds like a
great way to get your day started
normally we have to solve a separate set
of equations for each of the phases or
material types present but because of
this proposed method is able to put them
in one unified equation it scales well
with the number of materials within the
simulation this is not only convenient
from a theoretical standpoint but it
also Maps well to parallel architectures
and the results shown in the video will
run on a relatively high-end consumer
and video card this is remarkable as it
should not be taken for granted that a
new fluid simulation technique runs well
on the GPU the result indeed indicate
that the number of phases only have a
mild effect on the execution time of the
algorithm a nice and general framework
for fluid solid interactions these
solutions elasto-plastic solids and
deformable bodies what a fantastic value
proposition I could watch and play with
these all day I'll try my best to resist
but in case the next episode is coming
late you know where I am the quality of
the paper is absolutely top tier and if
you like physics you're going to have
lots of fun reading it thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
[Music]